[Music]
you know how we do it playa we got
everything for tonight
[Music]
that's why you moved you make a bad face
into your chocolate depressed me I see
truck I get excited to say I'm a fat
[ __ ] I'm the last of the real fat [ __ ]
what's going on out there you bad
[ __ ] three church coming your
way
just get the fun ready and all the DEF
utensils
[Music]
[Music]
we gotta take the bad spirits out of
this [ __ ] you understand me look
at that that's like a Snow Mountain
that's right
[Music]
oh [ __ ] bad [ __ ] you pick a
good night tonight
[Music]
it's always a good night [ __ ] March
first pay the rent [ __ ] you were
thinking about doing this this week and
get the UFC
I don't think so [ __ ] the rent is due
you're gonna have to go see the Russian
at a bar surrounded by [ __ ]
immigrants hiding from Trump
it don't matter it's the pre Church baby
uncle Joey here we got all types of
[ __ ] reef here look at this bud look
at this run down to you leave a bud with
me in the morning you're gonna have a
problem when you get back from work so
[ __ ] media all coming at you we got
some end of Gugino gaming oh [ __ ] in the
cat can we got a bunch of tools to that
we got [ __ ] a dick
oh [ __ ] directly from the one I jus some
shitty groan and radiation that gives us
the cancer people already gonna dial I
think that a couple days left [ __ ] give
it to me I don't give a [ __ ] it's got
radiation in it I don't give a [ __ ] I
need some weed
what radiation you got some [ __ ]
chocolates here we [ __ ] around you
understand it for that oh la Luna we're
going to the moon tonight
[Music]
Oh No
[Music]
it's [ __ ] massages pukin already
nothing training I'm telling you that
this guy eats fake trouble on the
weekends he [ __ ] because I watch him
he'd say you don't puke he only gets
cranky when he's over here
[Music]
I'll put up user asses his [ __ ] trophy
the devil says your Uncle Joe we're here
I missed you my bucket I hope you're
well I had a tremendous day the family a
little jiu-jitsu a little [ __ ]
tactical friend uncle Joey's gonna try
to put the pieces together everyday a
little right now not with my baby she
was sick tonight and that's it we're
here [ __ ]
[Music]
we pay something it's not like [ __ ]
eat a nice edible I know once day night
when everybody else is banging their
head against the wall
and we got all the answers you know Sam
and it's Ash Wednesday so the next one
was smoke I put an ash on my own [ __ ]
head
[Music]
oh yeah
oh yeah [ __ ] it's a beautiful
night I got Lisa ACK
I got my man tape Fletcher coming up in
this [ __ ] and that's the way we're
gonna work it out for that you
understand me
so if you having some problem with your
[ __ ] life you can't put the pieces
together
uncle Kate's here tonight he's not here
yeah his number I know where the [ __ ] is
that he just called it might be a couple
minutes late and that's it you bad
[ __ ] but we'll be in smoking
repeat are we doing never a dull moment
and uncle Joey's world with his [ __ ]
nephews are here get ready to golf
yong-dae team hang up now I wanna hit no
[ __ ] stories later your mom she found
you with a Playboy magazine you were
passed out I don't need this [ __ ]
[Music]
you see baby I wanna oh really
[Music]
there you go there you go there's a real
[ __ ] ask Wednesday at the church right
now [ __ ] let's switch it up a little
bit let's see what this indicas about
let's [ __ ] bongs and my man Tino gave
me speed we commend this guy I love him
to death
know them for years you gotta take this
[ __ ] Punk piece right here running
through that then you shut this little
[ __ ] dots right near the [ __ ] guys
and what do you got there you got a
[ __ ] mental explosion I'm saying some
people would have a nervous [ __ ]
breakdown what do you say and that's it
that's that we got a couple minutes he's
getting off the 101 lead to chocolate
please like I told you this [ __ ] guy
don't eat [ __ ] on the weekends he gets
like a Hershey bar and cuts it in half
and he gets any cuts that have you heard
of before who cares the [ __ ] he does my
used to do them with the TV I can't be
mad I can't be mad at me learn nothing
uncle Joey don't listen to him see how
do the chocolates on the weekends his
[ __ ] [ __ ]
he [ __ ] put something different in
there change of the labels you don't
think I know but I [ __ ] know I
invented that movie I'm saying I
invented that [ __ ] move
you know these [ __ ] people think I
just fell off the Banana Boat let's
finish this up we'll split this beast
you finish her chocolate yeah what are
you waiting on
I wanted this take ten [ __ ] years
almost this tape here we go
[ __ ] a little [ __ ] The Doors
here for you get you nice and calm
take your anxiety medication [ __ ]
uncle Joey's coming in
[Music]
come here Lele Lele his nipples are hard
and [ __ ] he was watching the Jewish porn
when I came in yet literally you don't
know he's gonna go deep tonight
well sprinkle impetus liquid acid on the
chocolate yeah there you go
[ __ ] what'd I tell you he doesn't
think I know he fakes the chopper on the
weekends
[Music]
[Music]
nice hey you know that ladder miss
Dorsey training is paying off and [ __ ]
he's a backdoor man [ __ ] what do you
think should we dip the chocolate liquid
ass in [ __ ] get the parties done
that's different oh my god this fresh
chocolate smells like a [ __ ] foot
after jujitsu
[Music]
nice and easy nobody gets that feeling
so he's insane if you start thinking and
start [ __ ] and look whatever how long
am I gonna be hard for I don't just eat
the [ __ ] thing you shut your [ __ ]
mouth all right we'll worry about that
later we got milk we got bread we'll
worry about that later
we won't let your freak on just eat the
tank you shut the [ __ ] up
the people are ask questions all these
Gentiles what's it gonna do to me huh
you're gonna wake up with Cosby's dick
in your ear I don't know I don't [ __ ]
know it's gonna do to you everybody's
different you wanna see the [ __ ] W
want to play in the ball yard you gotta
come [ __ ] mill the [ __ ] you think
we're giving away whatever here
[Music]
I thought I'd wait the up with joy and
don't throw away the truffle I'm
watching this [ __ ] throw [ __ ]
away he doesn't know that I know that he
knows he takes the Hershey bars on the
weekends he drinks him in half he opens
it up he puts it he breaks it open in
front of you guys then he'd say he gets
a Hershey bar and he cuts it down the
middle so it gives you the illusion that
he look good take him another one to eat
this [ __ ] is why we're here
oh he's at home in front of the [ __ ]
periscope he's like PA car daddy
talking [ __ ] mingling with his wife
[Music]
what'd you say
put shallots in there [ __ ] that I'm
doing a periscope don't be talking to me
[ __ ] [ __ ] is wrong with people
Trump is watching can you imagine when
that trunk knocks on your door with
eight guys and they take you back the
elation of origin and you imagine that
how [ __ ] up that would be I keep
[ __ ] around it's gonna happen to me
trunk line I'm not gonna [ __ ] off his
door with six heist [ __ ] and
they gonna take me right back to cube
and drop me off on one panel obey and
then what you guys gonna come [ __ ] get
young people Joey you gotta leave me in
there what are you gonna do ego you
can't walk on one leg it's [ __ ]
Wednesday night all right you got
Thursday in front you got Thursday in
front you can't walk on one leg
[Music]
we're doing it here tonight
you want to come down to the lounge
you're gonna get hit by a [ __ ] but of
indica that'll knock the eyeball out
having put crazy glue on my lids before
just to keep them [ __ ] open I'm
telling you this weed is [ __ ]
sensation we don't [ __ ] around with
listen
the ship was smoking nowadays we got
independent [ __ ] just
contacting us like Joey this is 29 a
half
this is dirty and it's over it's all
we've got time for that [ __ ]
pineapple Express in this [ __ ] you were
smoking two years ago that don't do
nothing here nothing
so you gotta show up with heavy labels
if you don't show up with skulls and
crossbones I don't smoke that [ __ ]
[ __ ] and that's it that's been good
time you got
[Music]
what are you gonna do the [ __ ]
cameraman slipping while we're here let
me fill up another boat you know we do
it you throw up another ball we get hide
together we have a nice little time
right along the st. that the same
[ __ ] brain surgeon you're here
there's just a bunch of jerk-offs
getting together we got nothing better
to do
I smoked a little gold the savage
looking at you in full effect tonight
speak to me old Duke this one ladies
we're gonna raffle this off you have to
take a picture with this in your monkey
and send it back and we'll smoke it and
see what happened people would do that I
don't give a [ __ ] what are you
[Music]
you lost me there for a minute that was
like Martin Sheen Apocalypse Now coming
at you that but if it's this we've so
good my eyes crooked it's officially
crooked only people with autism and a
couple retards have it where they
[ __ ] right eye is crooked
this weed has made me [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's how to do this and you want to
sit there and eat [ __ ] kale I'll [ __ ]
yourself
we're all over here killing
[ __ ] you understand me hey what
do you got though it's a beautiful
[ __ ] night I'm happy you join the
uncle Joey I missed you guys too they
had a good day the baby was sick she
didn't go to school you know so what are
you gonna do I gotta take care of this I
did my thing my shoulders are [ __ ] on
fire from a little [ __ ] steel bat
work at it before jujitsu I'm white
doctor that my body was vibrating after
class and it's in the hot water for like
[ __ ] 20 minutes I take two ibuprofen
so yeah was on fire I got killed today
there were so many people that all we
did was break the guard
you know she I keep breaking the guard
breaking my god breaking the guard I
broke one guard on all six
there'll be else's crawling me around
but I was almost there I'll kill the
[ __ ] keep showing up see you next week
I break two clocks and that my pen tally
I'm all right I don't need to be Bruce
Lee a [ __ ] flying to the end
but that's it and that's that uncle Joey
coming at you directly nicely stone
everybody knows where they stand
hold on one second I gotta change this
[ __ ] song here and spring I've been
as down since God knows yet is the last
song and then we'll leave you alone I'm
not gonna bother you on that one
you think I'm one of those [ __ ]
creepy people I'm not gonna bother your
[ __ ] night I don't need the
aggravation I got enough problems on my
like I'll lay over here
puking from the chocolate we still got
this for a nightcap tonight this when I
go home tonight yeah I gotta go to
acupuncture twelve so I can't sleep in
late cuz I got the baby I got the baby
tomorrow but I gotta go to acupuncture
twelve and I am I gonna get hypnotized
before and then I got a [ __ ] show it
to Comedy Store tomorrow night with the
boys
Skyler Stalin woman Jay mooring those
[ __ ] savages and then not next week
but the week after I'm coming to
Baltimore it's all over the Ravens
they're expecting me and [ __ ] Joe Flacco
is [ __ ]
you guys was looking mean oh this [ __ ]
old man is crazy and crazy but you know
what the second part of that is I don't
give a [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] well you
want me to do you babies I'm gonna be a
Starbucks ton of people [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] stories about me and Europe and
Belgium I don't need that aggravation
I'd rather stick to myself the exact
actual people on the stand I'm a long
[ __ ] wolf if I don't see leave Monday
and Wednesday I would see [ __ ] ya
muhawwil
please wipe don't let him out go play
cars in the daytime he can't be out
Italy even we don't show up he still has
to [ __ ] go report to the Commission
he's over there digging like a half a
[ __ ]
[Music]
unless she goes to the buzzsaw you can't
go play cards at night just gonna eat in
the morning like a vagabond we'll be
back you too what is it youtube.com
slash ceased as Joey Diaz always here
for your mother [ __ ] always willing
to smoke a bowl with you guys why not I
know you guys have blown it back into
the screen you should be because you're
professionals young as man
only amateurs would be sitting at a
[ __ ] bubbles watching the [ __ ]
screen you [ __ ] two at a time
Bob Marley in the background go Uncle
Joe go [ __ ]
I smoke another one did you smoke we'll
put the ashes on your Floyd I don't give
a [ __ ] with a Jewish Swahili and Muslim
let's do it out of respect for the
church you go to sleep you have a nice
dream but smoking reefer with Jimi
Hendrix's up right over only snore
you can put a Jewish star yeah I got a
listen I got nothing as Jewish does I
[Music]
love your [ __ ] I'll see you in
10 minutes youtube.com slash seized last
Joey Diaz stay black